wir haben Verstärkung bekommen bei uns
im Studio zu Besuch bei uns der
spd-experte für Flüchtlingspolitik Lars
castelluxe schönen guten Tag Herr
kastellucci einmal ganz persönlich wenn
Sie diese Bilder der vergangenen Tage
der vergangenen Stunden dort sehen aus
dem Grenzgebiet was gehen in ihnen für
Gefühle um haben sie Sorge vor dem was
auf uns zukommen könnte tausende die
nach Deutschland wollen oder haben sie
Mitgefühl vor allen Dingen Mitleid mit
all denen die dort in der Kälte sitzen
am Zaun stehen frieren und sich Gedanken
machen um Ihre ganz persönliche Zukunft
ja ist ja kein Gegensatz was sie gerade
schildern also einmalig war unter
anderem auch Lesbos als ich dort das
Lager besucht habe ging es mir auch
nicht gut das sind immer schlimme Bilder
und ich finde Politiker müssen sich vom
Elend in der Welt berühren lassen sonst
braucht man sie nicht sonst werden sie
nicht tätig werden und es geht mir bei
der Person die bei mir im Wahlkreis Büro
und Schicksal hat genauso wie wenn man
jetzt solche Fernsehbilder bekommt ist
das eine aber ich bin auch
offensichtlich denn wir haben in den
letzten Jahren ja auch vieles erlebt und
auch Lösungen erarbeitet und deswegen
werden wir auch diese Krise meistern
werden weiß dann denn es handelt sich ja
im Kern nicht um den Migrationsfrage
hier sondern es ist hier ein Verbrecher
unterwegs der Menschen an diese Grenze
verbringt und ich denke darüber sollten
wir jetzt auch sprechen nach meistern
sieht es aber im Moment nicht aus in der
vorletzten Nacht wurde der Grenzzaun
durchschnitten immer wieder sehen wir
auch Bilder von Menschen die dort
ausharren die dort frieren die zu einem
Jahr Spielball geworden sind was ist
ihre Lösung erschlagen
dieses Diktators Lukaschenko ich nenne
das staatlichen Menschenhandel das ist
leider eine Kategorie die wir noch nicht
rechtlich gefasst haben wir sind damit
von Erdogan schon mal konfrontiert
worden und jetzt lernen wir das auch in
Belarus kennen ja überrascht wir werden
uns wir dürfen uns an solche Sachen
nicht gewöhnen sondern wir müssen dafür
so wie wir für andere Angriffe auch uns
wappnen müssen wir uns rüsten und müssen
wir auch die rechtlichen Vorkehrungen
treffen ich bin dafür dass man jemanden
wie Lukaschenko für so etwas anzeigen
und vor allem Gericht stellen kann weil
das ist eine ganz ganz schäbige Art der
Bedrohung die hier auf dem Rücken von
ganz armen Menschen stattfindet und
deswegen ist unsere erste Aufgabe das
auch zu unterbrechen und weil sie sagen
dass jetzt zu wenig passiert passiert
meistens zu wenig wenn wir irgendwo
eingeladen sind und das kann man auch
nur zugestehen aber wir wirken jetzt ein
auf alle Partnerländer auf die Länder
von denen die Menschen losziehen auf die
Fluggesellschaften und wir haben dabei
auch schon erste Erfolge dass diese
Linien unterbrochen werden noch mal es
geht hier einerseits um das Schicksal
der Menschen die vor Ort sind da geht es
um Humanität und da müssen wir auch
tätig werden da muss auch Polen uns
unterstützen aber vor allem geht es
darum diesen Zustrom zu stoppen ganz
kurz was sind die Erfolge weil sie sie
gerade nennen das heißt es gehen weniger
Flüge definitiv in den vergangenen
Stunden nach Minsk und Moskau also das
hier bestätigen wir haben hier weiterhin
eine Zahl von vielleicht knapp 1000 die
täglichen Belarus ankommen allerdings
sind wir ja nicht dort und können
durchzählen deswegen kann ich Ihnen das
jetzt nicht im Detail bestätigen aber
ich weiß dass wir beispielsweise mit der
irakischen Regierung oder mit der
jordanischen Regierung schon erfolgreich
sind und dort auch begonnen wird diese
Flüge zu unterbinden
man hört überhaupt gar nichts von Olaf
Scholz wir erklären sich dass er ist ja
womöglich bald Kanzler ist auf jeden
Fall Vizekanzler heute wird der sprechen
es geht aber vermutlich um Corona sollte
er sich nicht zu Wort melden in dieser
Krise also Olaf Scholz wird jetzt gerade
diesen Minuten sein Sakko wahrscheinlich
zu machen und vorne hin ans Rednerpult
sich langsam aufmachen wenn es um Corona
geht das ist auch wichtig die Menschen
haben verdient dass es hier Orientierung
gibt aber es gehört sich auch dazu diese
Themen ins deutsche Parlament auch
wieder stärker zu bringen und deutlich
zu machen dass wir hier diese Regelungen
auch treffen und auch die Verantwortung
dafür übernehmen das wird heute
stattfinden und gleich
im Anschluss wird es eine Debatte geben
im Deutschen Bundestag bei der wird der
Bundesaußenminister Heiko Maas sprechen
ich denke das ist auch eine gute
Arbeitsteilung Scholz nicht dass er was
sagt oder erwarten sie dass er zu diesem
Thema was sagt nicht nur zu Corona ich
denke dass heute für ihn das Thema
Corona ist und dass wir dann eine
Debatte haben in der der Außenminister
die richtigen Worte finden wird aber das
ist die Reaktion von Olaf in den
vergangenen Tagen auch wir hatten ihn ja
angefragt schon vorgestern da sagte er
heute nicht also heute an diesem
Donnerstag einen Tag später ist dann
auch wieder heute nicht das Problem ist
sie haben es hier mit einem haben sie ja
selber gesagt Verbrecher mit einem
Diktator zu tun der spart nicht an
klaren Worten der setzt uns ordentlich
unter Druck der schickt die Flüchtlinge
sofort an die Grenze und liegt dann
verbal noch mal nach seine Soldaten
stehen an der Grenze ihm gegenüber
polnische Soldaten in der Nacht
Warnschüsse und wir haben keine
Regierung und das Gefühl ist man ist
hilflos im Moment da äußert sich noch
nicht jemand klar und Olaf Scholz eben
auch nicht warum auch heute nicht
also ich freue mich über Ihr Interesse
an Olaf Scholz und hoffe auch dass das
über sehr sehr viele Jahre jetzt nicht
abreißen wird aber wir haben ja schon
bei der letzten Regierungsbildung
gesehen dass es sehr sehr lange gedauert
hat und da sind auch Leute auf mich
zugekommen hört ja der Regierung an er
ist ja Vizekanzler das vergisst ja das
wollte ich ihnen gerade bestätigen was
sie gerade sagen wir haben schon vor
vier Jahren haben wir eine sehr sehr
lange Phase der Regierungsbildung gehabt
und die Menschen sind auch etwas unruhig
gewesen ja fehlt da nicht irgendwas
funktioniert da eigentlich alles und wir
haben gesehen wir sind über diese Zeit
gut drübergekommen ja es ist eine
besondere Zeit man kann jetzt auch nicht
wir haben parallel laufende
Verhandlungen und dann müssen sehen dass
das alles gut orchestriert wird aber
genau daran wird ja auch gearbeitet und
wenn wir jetzt sehen dass wir jetzt
Mitte November haben und hoffentlich in
der ersten Dezemberhälfte dann den
kanzlerwellen dann haben wir das ja auch
geschafft aber noch mal um das auf den
Punkt zu bringen er sagt ja gerade
nichts offenbar das haben sie ja gerade
bestätigt mit ihren Worten weil er diese
Verhandlung ordentlich orchestrieren
möchte sagen sie das heißt der würde im
Moment riskieren mit klaren Worten
Richtung Lukaschenko und Putin das sind
die Ampel möglicherweise ja irgendwie
aus dem aus dem
aus dem aus dem Griff Gerät dass er das
da nicht zusammengebunden bekommt ihm
ist im Moment die Ampel wichtiger als
dann klare Worte zu schicken nach Minsk
und nach Moskau also ich teile Ihre
Kritik nicht aber möglicherweise werden
wir uns da auch nicht einigen ich bin
der Auffassung das ist an klaren Worten
an die Adresse von Herrn Lukaschenko in
keiner Weise fehlt wir haben eine
amtierende Bundesregierung die auch
weiter geschäftsführend im Amt ist die
macht ihre Arbeit und parallel stehe
beispielsweise ich Ihnen jetzt hier auch
zur Verfügung wir schauen mal rein Olaf
Scholz hat nämlich was gesagt das war
aber im August 2020 da hat er mit dir
gesprochen und da ging es um lukaschen
ich bin fest davon überzeugt dass dieser
Präsident keine Legitimation mehr hat
sonst würde er nicht mit so
unglaublicher so brutaler Gewalt agieren
und die Tatsache dass sich überhaupt
niemand gegenwärtig einschüchtern lässt
dass viele Menschen sehr viel riskieren
ist ja auch eine große Hoffnung der
Demokratie denn letztendlich ist die
Demokratie ja etwas das aus dem Volk
wächst und auf der Kraft des Volkes
beruht und das zeigt sich hier ja diese
Hoffnung wurde zerschlagen damals muss
man sagen Lukaschenko dennoch an der
Macht an der Macht geblieben wir
erinnern uns alle aus an diese Bilder
die wir damals aus Belarus gesehen haben
wie schon sie jetzt dort in die Zukunft
was muss passieren dort am Zaun werden
darüber gesprochen immer wieder hören
wir Sanktionen es wird fast
überparteilich das gleiche gefordert
aber um die Frage was passiert mit den
Menschen die dort jetzt in diesen
Minuten wenn wir sprechen frieren und
rüber wollen sind Sie rein oder sollen
sie in den Wäldern bleiben also erstmal
klare Kante gegenüber dem reg
Transaktionen
konnten sperren und diese Dinge so da
haben wir die Situation vor Ort und wir
haben klare Grundsätze an den
europäischen Außengrenzen sollen die man
zu Tode kommen wäre es dort hinschafft
der soll anständig behandelt werden da
muss die Menschenwürde gelten und die
Gesetze und ihre das Recht dass wir eben
auch geschaffen haben wir sind im 70
Jahr der Genfer Flüchtlingskonvention
die ist sehr bedroht uns unser Anliegen
ist es dass wir sie auch erhalten können
auch in Zukunft also an dieser Grenze
muss Recht und Ordnung gelten das heißt
dass die das grenzmanagement auch
funktionieren muss das gilt übrigens für
beide Seiten weder haben Migranten ein
recht mit weisszangen sich versuchen
selber ein Weg durch zu schaffen aber
umgekehrt sind pushbacks illegal
deswegen bin ich dafür und tritt die
SPD-Fraktion dafür ein dass frontextor
zum Einsatz kommt und eine an
Menschenrechten orientierte Grenzpolitik
dort wieder
nicht der Fall also es funktioniert
nicht frontext ist nicht da die Menschen
sind aber dann die Frage ganz konkret
die Menschen die dort jetzt sind
reinholen in die EU oder nicht also
zunächst mal geht es um humanitäre Hilfe
vor Ort also da muss der Zugang
gewährleistet sein die Verletzten über
den Zaun werfen oder die
Hilfsorganisationen Zugang finden müssen
und sie kennen das ja an anderen Orten
auch dass dann stabile Unterkünfte
stattfinden dass die Menschen erst
versorgt werden was Ernährung was
Medizin angeht das heißt da müsste
Lukaschenko zustimmen an der Stelle wo
sie sind muss Hilfe zugänglich sein das
ist der erste Punkt und dann ist klar
dass wir darüber sprechen dass das
natürlich kein Dauerzustand ist und dann
wird es
das geben was wir rechtlich noch mal es
geht um Recht und Ordnung und das auch
durchzusetzen ist völlig klar wenn
jemand an den Grenzen auftaucht an den
europäischen Außengrenzen und um
Aufnahmen um Schutz nachsucht dann gehen
Verfahren los dann geht übrigens auch
los dass wir registrieren müssen dass
wir wissen müssen um wen handelt es sich
denn da eigentlich dann ist eine
Sicherheits Prüfung nötig und wenn es
ein Asylverfahren geben soll weil die
Leute danach fragen dann muss das auch
stattfinden das sind die Dinge die vor
uns liegen und am Ende wird es auch im
Verteilung gehen in Länder die dazu
bereit sind aber im Moment ist es
tatsächlich die Aufgabe unmittelbar
humanitäre Hilfe dort auch ankommen zu
lassen und da sind wir dabei alle
möglichen Druck und Gespräche zu führen
dass das auch stattfinden kann noch
einmal ein letztes Mal ganz konkret die
Frage weil all die Fragen und Antworten
die sie gegeben haben die sind
unzweifelhaft wichtig und trotzdem lösen
Sie vor Ort gerade das aktuelle Problem
nicht die wirken möglicherweise
langfristig aber konkret am Zaun dort
die tausenden die da stehen sind sie
froh um jeden der reinkommt oder froh um
jeden der am Zaun stehen bleibt auf der
nicht-eu-seite froh zu sein ist jetzt
hier keine Kategorie sondern ich habe
gesagt wir haben Rechte und wir haben
Gesetze und die haben überall zu gelten
für Leute die hier im Land leben und ihr
normales Leben nachgehen und arbeiten
und das gilt auch wenn jemand an einer
Grenze kommt gibt es keine privat
Gelegenheit da einfach drüber zu kommen
sondern es gibt Regeln die geschaffen
worden sind nach denen das statt zu
finden hat das geht im Moment nicht weil
die polnische Regierung mit der mit
Polizei und Militär dort aufgetreten ist
und die Menschen überhaupt keinen Zugang
zu verfahren haben und wir unser Ansatz
ist dass ich das schnellstmöglich ändern
muss sie bauen jetzt hier ein sehr
starken Druck auf das ist schnell gehen
muss das ist genau das was ich wenn ich
in Gremien sitze auch mache sie haben
vorhin auch gesagt der lukaschen und Co
macht doch und wo bleibt denn unsere
Reaktion aber es ist für Politik auch
ganz wichtig sich nicht treiben zu
lassen und immer nur angetrieben zu sein
sondern konsequent bei den Dingen zu
sein die wir als Lösungen gefunden haben
und denen nach und nach immer besser zu
Durchsetzung zu verhelfen und da sind
wir dran und manchmal auch schnell
reagieren ich finde auch dass dann die
letzten Monate gezeigt und ich glaube
das sehen wir jetzt besonders auch bei
dieser Krise da glaube ich kann man sich
nicht nur auf das verlassen was man für
ein Regelwerk geschaffen hat man steht
von der neuen Situation